Well, it can't be the normal force on the rock, the rock is in the air.
The ground isn't pushing up on it and there is normal force.
I say the best answer was the pulling force. This person is pulling down on the rope.
Depending on how hard they pull, they can control the tension in this rope.
So we know that the tension is equal to this pulling force.
And it's always going to be true no matter how many pulls to that,
and if this tension force is balancing the weight, which it is,
well then, these forces are also equal to the weight (mg).
And (mg) is about 1000 N because the (m) is 100 kg and (g) is 10 m/s²,
actually 9.8 but we're using 10.
This doesn't seem like a great improvement.
We're still using a force equal to the weight to lift this object.
Why not just pick it up? Well, that's why this is called the simple pulley.